[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
I'm Carson.
And I'm an Engineer of RStudio.
And I'd like to show
you some work we've
been doing to make custom
theming easier inside of Shiny
and R Markdown.
I'd like to show you
two different packages.
The first is bslib, which
allows you to essentially style
any of the components that are
rendered by your web browser
inside of an app or document.
The second-- thematic allows
you to essentially translate
the CSS styles that you
include in your browser
and allow them to set new
defaults for your static R
plots.
So to start using
bslib with shiny--
the first thing that
you're going to want to do
is to call this bs_theme
function to create
a theming object,
which you can then
give to the theme argument
of essentially any page
layout inside of shiny that
wants to utilize Bootstrap.
Now these currently by default,
what this is going to do
is actually upgrade
your application
from using Bootstrap 3
to using Bootstrap 4.
So if you happen to put
this inside of an existing
application and you
encounter any issues,
just know that you can also
downgrade to Bootstrap 3
when using the bslib package.
And in the future,
we plan on supporting
Bootstrap 5 and higher.
And regardless of what
Bootstrap version you're using,
you can easily customize
the main colors and fonts
of your application.
So here I've set the background
and foreground colors
to a dark mode
for my application
and the next I could choose
to set some important accent
colors like the primary
or secondary color.
And finally, I will set
a different base font
from the Bootstrap defaults.
So here I'm going to use the
font_google function, which
does a lot of work for me
in terms of making sure
that the font files are
available for the end user,
even if they don't have
an internet connection.
And also keep in mind with
this bs_theme function,
you have access to hundreds of
different more specific styling
settings, if you want to get
more targeted with your styles
and to quickly preview
a given theme object,
try out this bs_theme_preview
function, which essentially
runs a demo app where you can
see all the various components
that your theme might impact.
Now if you were to
include a bs_theme object
inside of your own
application, you
might notice that the
styling of your application
doesn't propagate to the static
R plots that are generated
by your Shiny app.
And this is one of
the reasons why we
created the thematic package.
If you call this thematic_shiny
function just prior
to running the
shiny application,
then all of the static R plots
that are generated by the Shiny
app will use the CSS
styles on their container
to set new theming
defaults on the R side.
bslib also provides an
interactive theming tool,
which allows you to quickly
try out different theme settings
and seeing how that theme
renders in real-time.
This theming tool can be used
with any Shiny application
by calling the
bs_themer function.
The only requirement is that
you call the bs_themer function
inside of the server function.
And that you're using
this interactive themer
with Bootstrap 4.
Also keep in mind that if you're
running this themer locally,
any of the interactive
changes that you make
are captured with R code
and admitted to R console.
So that you can copy
paste those changes
into your theme creation.
Now if you'd like to use these
theming tools with R Markdown,
the first thing to
know is that you
can pass these theme
settings into the theme
parameter of an HTML document.
In addition, if you'd like
to theme your document
with the interactive
theming tool,
you'll have to first add a
shiny runtime to your documents
YAML matter and then call
the bs_themer function
inside of the server side code.
Now if you'd like these
real time changes in the CSS
on the page to influence the R
plots rendered by the document,
you'll first have
to enable thematic.
And then also make sure that
your rendering your plots
through Shiny's renderPlot.
It's also worth noting that
the matter can be used anywhere
to create any sort of
file format that you want.
We've seen it used with Shiny
in our markdowns HTML document
to create PNG images, where
the styles are automatically
informed by CSS styles.
However, you can also
enable thematic and give it
the actual color codes for
a background, foreground
and accent color, similar to
how we provided those things
to a bs_theme object.
And finally, I would like
to thank you for listening.
As well as provide these
links to the slides
as well as documentation,
where you can learn more.
Thank you.